قال نائب رئيس مجلس الامن الروسي ديمتري
ان قرار المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه بمحاكمه
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين سياتي
بعواقب وخيمه على القانون
قال على قناته في موقع تيليجرام ان قضاه
المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه قرروا محاكمه
رئيس قوه نوويه لا تشارك في المحكمه محذرا
من عواقب ذلك وذكر فان اسس ومبادئ القانون
قد انهارت وانا احدا لن يذهب بعد الان الى
اي هيئات دوليه وسيتفاوض الجميع فيما
بينهم وقال ان الحلقه الاكثر تشويها
للمصداقيه مرتبطه بجرائم واشنطن في
افغانستان والعراق والتي لم تستطع المحكمه
فعل اي شيء بشانها حسب قولها
من جهتها دعت الصين المحكمه الجنائيه
الدوليه لاحترام حصانه رئيس الدوله
وتجنب الكيل بمكيالين جاء ذلك على خلفيه
قرار المحكمه اصدار مذكره توقيف بحق
الرئيس الروسي فيلاد مير بوتين بدعوى
مسؤوليته عن جرائم حرب الخارجيه الصينيه
اكدت في بيانها اليوميه على انه ينبغي على
المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه التمسك بموقف
موضوعي وحيادي كما قالت الصين انها ستلعب
دورا بناء في تعزيز محادثات السلام بخصوص
الازمه الاوكرانيه واكدت ان الرئيسين
الصيني والروسي سيناقشان سبل تعزيز
التنسيق الاستراتيجي وضخ زخم جديد في
تنميه العلاقات الثنائيه